what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
since the dawn of modern man we have
continually suffered an existential
crisis questions like why are we here
and where did we come from reside in the
back of our minds some find answers in
the belief of a God up there listening
others turn to science and technology
but for mutants the answer can be found
in history
Oh
in the early days of Earth and
approximately some 1 billion years ago
there was sublime
and Archaea coming into existence
through the evolutionary process these
perfect twins were the first biological
organisms but were also locked into
battle and governed by three imperatives
replicate dominate and survive to ensure
a survival sublime banished his sister
to the cosmos and there she remained
where she was forgotten by everyone back
on earth sublime inherited this new
world and watched as it began to take
form washed his mountains rose and sea
levels dropped as the Elder Gods waged
war among themselves and were interned
destroyed by demagogues as this Evan
flow of life continued for the next five
hundred million years
sublime was present when single-cell
life forms became multi-cell life-forms
and eventually gave way to animals and
man learning of his ability to jump from
one organism to the next and possess
their bodies the world had become
sublimes oyster giving him the ability
to sow conflict and reap war cross the
planet continuing in this manner
sublime bore witness as the Celestials
arrived on earth 1 million years ago as
part of their continued grand experiment
to the cosmos met by Gaia following
their war with the serpent men a nomadic
tribe known as The Wanderers stood as a
missing link between ape and modern man
beseeching the tribe to accept the gifts
of the Celestials this act by Gaia was a
byproduct of necessity with the initial
war of the Elder Gods having long since
passed the Elder Gods set was one of the
few who managed to escape to a pocket
dimension and his own certain death
seeking to continually enter into the
earthly dimension and an effort to
retake the planet for himself but being
continually defeated by demagogues
Gaia knew that a time would come when
set would rise to a level of power
beyond that of the god Slayer seeking to
ensure Earth's continued protection the
arrival of the Celestials was fortuitous
and that it would allow for them to
modify
the genes of man and give rise to powers
of extraordinary levels finding
themselves split into three groups and
after several weeks of experimentation
the first
hether genes modified to an unstable
state by zero on the tester and went
forward as the deviance this second
group was hyper evolved by Nizar the
calculator and took on the appearance of
modern man after which they were imbued
with cosmic energies and went forward as
the Eternals finally the third group was
given a latent gene by Oneg the prober
which would bring forth humanity's true
potential at some point in the future
we're the Eternals took up residence on
the mountaintops and eventually space
itself the deviants took up residence
underground finding their unstable genes
brought forth unstable mutations deviant
society was a veritable hodgepodge of
distrust and anger lacking emotions of
compassion and love the deviants saw
themselves outpacing baseline humans in
their evolutionary race only ever
finding defeat in their conflicts
against the Eternals turning their
sights to the surface world by 20,000 BC
the deviants had created settlements
which in turn became kingdoms sprawling
out from their capital city of Lemuria
serving as a major trading hub for the
deviants themselves as well as the
Eternals of those human groups who'd not
been pressed gained in the servitude
Atlantis rose as a literal neutral
territory devoid of conflict and
something akin to a safe haven visiting
the earth a second time with the
intention of observing their experiments
the Celestials were angered to find that
humanity had been subjugated by the
deviants while the Eternals sat without
care seeing themselves as conquerors and
beyond approach where the deviants once
view the Celestials as their makers they
now viewed them as usurpers attending to
seize control of their kingdoms
launching an attack against the godly
beings and 18,000 BC the deviants were
deemed failures by arashan who judged
against them initiated a great Cataclysm
era shem and the celestial hosts watched
as the deviants were pushed to the brink
of extinction
their human slaves escaping on rafts or
else sunk with atlantis and most of the
Eternals fleeing earth with the earth
left to begin anew what remained of the
deviants relegated themselves to the
subterranean realm building their armies
in preparation for the next Celestials
visit while the remaining Eternals
opened their doors to surviving humans
thus humanity went forth and began to
multiply spreading itself to all four
corners of the world all while
blissfully unaware that in due time
their latent genes would activate a
mutant kind would begin to rise while
humanity enjoyed its new world Selene
was coming to power born in 17,000 BC a
full 1000 years after the great
Cataclysm Selene stood as the first
external possessing the mutant ability
to absorb the life force of those around
her unlike future mutations which would
activate in response to puberty or
heightened levels of stress Selene
was born with her powers slowly
siphoning off the life energies of her
mother who died during childbirth moving
to a small area off the coast of Spain
stories of this place involve pain
suffering and the vanishing of those who
travel too closely given a wide berth by
sailors and travelers those who
witnessed the denizens of this place
would call them angels or demons in
reality the island of demons contained a
tear in space-time which allowed access
to a pocket dimension within it resided
the Nayef end and the chay-ara femme
mutants who appeared both demonic and
angelic confined to this space following
a holy war between the two groups the
Nayef m and chay-ara fennel would
inspire tales of an ancient battle
between good and evil
spanning into the heavens and beyond
by 5,000 BC the expansion of humanity
and his latent eating genes was
beginning to increase born to the clinic
haba in Egypt's Valley of Kings as a
byproduct of its primitive beliefs in
Sabah NORs tribe considered his physical
appearance to be a bad omen cast aside
to die in the desert nor was saved by
Baal and his nomadic sandstorm errs
raised with the tribes ideologies newer
developed an extremist social Darwinists
belief that only the strong deserve to
survive proving his might through
ritualistic combat new arose among the
ranks of the sandstorms becoming one of
its most feared and capable warriors
completing his rite of passage and being
viewed as a man by the trod nor was
taken by Baal who revealed his destiny
learning that nor would eventually rise
to become one of our most powerful
mutants adopt the moniker apocalypse and
seize the world
Baal revealed that this prophecy was his
reason for adopting nor instead of
leaving him to his fate in the desert
however after learning of Nora's
existence came the Conqueror a
time-displaced villain turned pharaoh
had sought to use noir as a means of
securing his own legacy thus while newer
and Baal were continuing their journey
the armies of King slaughtered the
sandstorm errs and initiated a cave-in
leading King to believe that Noor had
been killed swearing an oath of
vengeance against King following the
death of Baal nor made his way to Egypt
slave pens and found himself the objects
of Neph Rees desires as the sister of
Ozymandias Nephi was lusted after by
many men none of whom looked to incur
the wrath of Kings top general however
for newer this was as much love as it
was access to court Nephi would grant
him an audience with Cain and the
revenge he so desired
but when he revealed his true appearance
Nephi was appalled and fled fearing his
disfigurements mourner saw his rise to
power coming through great battles or
conquests in reality his powers arose
through heartbreak lashing out and
destroying the armies of Egypt King fled
to the future who all knew 'red on the
mantle of apocalypse transformed
Ozymandias into a scribe and made
preparations
for global domination
[Music]
you
[Music]